[ __ ] rock monday you come see me in
Kansas City April 3rd and 4th then you
go to Columbus Ohio March I'm sorry
April 17th 18th and then in April
Charlotte comedy zone April 23 24 25 I
don't stop won't stop can't stop Brenda
no you can't stop peanut butter Falcon
and then I'm in Atlanta it's Friday
Atlanta Friday bucket theater New
Orleans Saturday criminal virus ain't
got [ __ ] on us
Atlanta Friday New Orleans Saturday one
show one night only next week Austin
Texas cap City South by Southwest might
be canceled but your sick friend here
ain't canceling you from company afraid
no coronavirus hot coming can't stop
won't stop can't stop that in March
Toronto one night that's almost sold out
Toronto March 26 Detroit March 27th
Minneapolis March 28th and then Ireland
UK England all in April get your tickets
right now peep at kake.com Atlanta New
Orleans see this Saturday
[Music]
well it's color Falcon it's it's
cockroach martini bar look man I don't
know why you call me thing butter okay
play me but hey I want people to know
people you buying a lot of [ __ ] for
never paying as bets ever try and pay me
I paid him three thousand dollars three
[ __ ] grand i uz what's up dawg I'm
gonna send you half is a listen
got your P's and Q's no I is you with
that fight Darko was not easy it's with
y'all
here's what here's what I have a
question I have a question for you rinse
is on it today like that wha
30 Vince oh I like Vince I back on that
back
don't worry low-cut socks not a big deal
kind of work gotta work on the shoes
look good though not bad right
I have a I have a question a fight
question explain to me Yoel I like he
plays possum that overhand left was
crazy
yes yes yes props to Izzy fer absorbing
that okay sure as he goes oh that guy
can explode like crazy that's not snap
I'll peanut butter nah-ha now III have a
question
number one you you don't do anything for
the first two rounds you go back to your
corner to corner says nothing to you
from what I could tell your corner says
nothing now I love where you going now
wait then I have another question I
watched the guy wrestle I watched that
he's a two-time world champion he beat
Cael Sanderson twice he is he is better
is better wrestler and there you can say
grappler is a good of grappler that is
Micah Bieber anybody everybody way more
decorous we know that he can put is he
on his back at will and I will go a step
further we know he can keep is he on his
back go peanut butter why in the world
when he when he closes distance like he
did when he gets is he down does he let
him up as opposed to just go from
transition to transition to transition
until he gets is he on the ground about
chain wrestling now I'm talking about
chain wrestling why again welcome you're
in the chain he's and again once again
you can't keep him from keeping you down
or keeping you keeping you on your back
because he goes from transition to
transition because the best in the world
at it because two times in a row and the
best grappler obviously didn't issue so
so I don't understand why he wouldn't
use his wrestling and why his coaches
aren't yelling at him constantly use
your wrestling used your wrestling and
and take a page at a khabees book
compete was in the front row he couldn't
look the cup even said hey should I do
it you do cool I got you
correct why why didn't he do that and
get the belt because it could or
something else do you thing about he's
42 - 42 years old that's the last time
shot he's everything right
why wouldn't you go for broke after the
first three rounds after the first three
when he went back to the corner his team
should be like dude our game plan to
counter the counter striker offseason
working he's [ __ ] up your leg we're
down three yeah maybe two either way
we're down yeah go for broke brother
this aren't this our last shots our last
broke wrestle get them down
go for a knockout we got to go out our
shield cuz we will never be back there
also he's the champ you have to take the
belts what you not from the chat you
have to take it we know this
so if is he decide to do that which he
wants them with
he's the kind of striker so you'd uh but
if is he want to do a different game
plan he can do that because he's the
champion it you're it's a home-field
advantage for him so you all being an
awakened you gotta take that [ __ ]
belt you're not gonna take it by sitting
there it soon earned that right no
that's not that's not that's not to give
it but also that's his corner who's ATT
some of the best in the very best of the
best best when you're going to the fifth
round and you're down four deathly three
if you're on you ELLs not to give them
that first time but definitely down
three for sure you're losing a fight
correct there's no chance you can win
the fight nobody says let's go for broke
in the fifth now did you guys really
think you were winning you were beating
the champ at that point we're down at
least three yeah 100 sent you down three
yeah what did the [ __ ] my only my only I
want to kiss your stupid ma'am I only
came in hot today
I'm hot I'm hot cuz I lost $3,000 my
thing is this my only thing is maybe yo
l-look this coach says don't [ __ ]
tell me to wrestle I don't want to hear
it from you guys I'm gonna beat him at
his own game I'm gonna beat about five
right that's fine alright let's say you
go on a rescues you worry about your
cardio so all right [ __ ] it don't
wrestle but then engage cuz you're down
three rounds it's probably for the
weirdest thing and I would also say you
something well maybe he doesn't he
doesn't have the mindset of a champion
he won world he was the world champion
here's the minds of course he's just
awkward fights here's the mindset I
think he's so worried about gassing out
knocked out mmm I think there's
something there's something deep inside
they worry about gasps announcer there's
a fear of fatigue height is a wrestle
although if you're if you were basically
come out of the womb with an underhook
and that's all you do
yes you really don't get that tired cuz
that's that's your background your body
that's what it knows her he you know
he's weird and where where is he like a
sweater dude you know what's weird about
him uh I'm sorry
it's alright you know what's weird about
him is even when he gets concussed his
first reaction is it to grapple its the
strike yeah which for a wrestlers very
long it's very straight in his blood
remember this is I believe his father
and his uncle were both Olympic boxers
laughs dude yeah we're gonna have a
moment of silence right now
because ul Romero with more twin workmen
comes in should we ask him what you'll
Romero's mindset sure Marc Maron's gonna
be all over that idea
Marc Maron probably never watched an MMA
fight it's like now that fight between
you Anna and ginger the great une engine
jack and that amazing
yang Jane is that her name Wei Lee Kang
Wei Lee yeah but bully leo say waily
waily both of the both of the most
incredible human beings they are both so
[ __ ] incredible I don't know what's
going on with both of them I don't know
how that fight was the crazy [ __ ] of
Epsilon who'd you have won in that fight
I have yo I don't know what I'm a
FEMINIST oh good
you sure heard the talk he gave me
coffee number one I am a feminist get
older dude hey dude you have winning
that fight I had you on him I had you on
a two but they need to rematch that
should been a draw I could because
depends are there drawers yeah yeah they
can be yeah they can be you give ten ten
rounds they should give some to that
should've been a draw but there's no
loser so would have been there's no
losers but yeah but there's no losers in
that and also the draw would have built
up the the rematch I had you on a
winning but I was like oh that this is
the one fight judge cake [ __ ] up
they can't pick wrong it I both are
winners whichever way you go it's your
cup of tea do you like tea or coffee
bowls are great and I'm biased towards
you honest oh my I was loved you like
Chinese people no I love the Chinese
people I'm not really sound like you
what's our Willie Chang Chang Chang no
I'm not whoa about the Chinese
government but then again that's okay
it's not their fault but I really admire
that woman did you see the one gentleman
from Dagestan or canuckistan
who was like women should be fighting
after the fight oh he said that good
well you keep that you keep up that
awesome belief my friend see how far
that gets you in life well and your
country by the way wolf yeah phenomenal
fighters but also but that's his
perspective Toby yeah like that's why he
was raised he'll know any better well
and I would say that GSP said the same
thing yeah
but we're growing up all of us we're all
growing up you think over there they
like this or changing our minds and
they're changing minds over there
believe it or not the way you change
minds is not necessarily by writing by
still there's something that's by doing
and those women are getting in and they
changed my mind
hey they change I had some of that
I'm not saying all of it but I had a lot
of eyes I still have it in me if it's a
really really pretty girl like page or
Tatiana or rich most of it and they're
like extremely hot and they get punched
in the face I feel different
yes if it's a dragon game punch in the
face I just do yeah I didn't grow up in
that I didn't grow up in that app and
that's what I mean and I'm not against
it by any means I love women find it fun
to that fight women fight men fight
that's one of the best fights I've ever
seen is that what bought it I'm just not
used to it but that's what I mean so I
am I understand why he has a culture
that is very patriarchal and and it's
frankly very chauvinistic
it's also why and I have to say this
whenever you see cultures like that you
won't see a lot of innovation coming out
of those cultures you you'll see one
kind of strength they define strength as
the guy with the biggest muscles in the
biggest club you see one of the shut
their gun yeah you don't see a whole lot
of you don't buy a lot of products from
Dagestan you don't you just don't see a
lot of artistic innovation community
home-cooked meals in the Spain house
yeah keep going what you do QC order you
see order there's a lot of emphasis on
order on the steel good time on
hierarchy all good you won't see a lot
of the Apple is not coming out of
country I'll create this I'm not coming
out of country also not spunk not a lot
of not not a lot of freaks come out
there you know I can see a lot of
open-minded sexual that is that's or
documents or the it's under the old good
since Afghanistan now there's a whole
lot of satellite dishes now one thing
you'll notice if you talk to some of the
CIA or the notes there's a lot there's a
whole no there's just a whole bunch of
porn watched in those households on but
under yeah yeah yeah so you know there's
there's that there's there Aleksandra
eight guys feed through the [ __ ] coal
because the three is race notion well
III think he should you still have to
you have to still have to say you got to
start you got a you're worthy of
criticism my friend and here's why we
don't tweet it out yeah like you know
could be feels exact same way but he's
on your tweet it now could be yeah and I
don't if you feel that way that's I
level if the issue with it at all if
that's your prerogative not your
perspective that's where you were born
that's cool man I think should open your
eyes but if you
dad and your trainers and your entire
culture and your societies that way well
you're gonna be them I understand why
he's that way I'd be doing which is
which is actually a form of ignorance I
think it's also then upon him to maybe
open his eyes and to grow like all my
big things don't tweet it out yeah you
can feel however you want but don't you
don't need announce to the world if you
want to tweet it out just be ready for a
fuckload of backlash are you think he
cares no but he might care and egg said
he doesn't corporate sponsors of the UFC
go we don't want to go like that
fighting and that can happen I'm
unfortunately or fortunately it's not
ever not ever in the UFC
never never really you don't think so
yeah I do and I guarantee you that
doesn't happen really I just could be
feels the same way and I trust me if
harley-davidson when I went hey we don't
like the way [ __ ] khabib spoke of
women this way can you not find this
card Dean would say suck my dick sure
sure
which I by the way I don't think anybody
should be censored for their point of
view I just think you should be ready
for the backlash that's me too if your
entry I'll just get ready but I don't
think he gives a flying [ __ ] yeah he's
usually a young man who's ignorant and
has been has been has been very pleased
yeah yeah but [ __ ] I mean how do you
argue how do you say that by the way
here's the other question it's doubly
ignorant when you watch a fight that
incredible how do you say that when you
watch those two on that level of sky
it's a weird time to do it like do it do
it today
I don't do it the night when the fight
that after watching a fight were you
watching the fight how do you argue
about it on this forehead oh my god
insane right what's her forehead looked
like now now well you now think of me
two actors what you can do is compress
the swelling I'm wearing a bandanna or a
thing I've never seen anything like it
clothes thing was ha making Canada
versus Jose oh and she had her nose
smack and those debts of smash you know
what she looks like she looks like the
alien of Family Guy
yeah that poor thing and now she's got
her basically uh that's our I thought
black Jesse right they wrapped it the
compress it that's long ago I remember
my cheek button yes I do bring that [ __ ]
up chance how long did that did that
take to the way after like two or three
days so I got a period and that's
growing on my cheek oh yeah
that's so well it's another angle right
there that's it right there
I am not pressing my tongue against my
cheek there check out the toots you got
some tits on you you got some tits
handsome kid though yeah oh that's a
great shot
let me see that shot I would put that on
that where he says Bren shot meets Ben
Rothwell that's a handsome look for real
that right there I'm serious
well that was a cloudy it does that was
after a crow cup no is that there Ben
Rothwell I think no my face wasn't
marked up that's a great I'm sorry but
that's a great bet says Brendan meats
been wrong that's a great tip before
that's a great we didn't do in Montreal
either you won that fight after that
with a broken nose but that's a great
picture that should be framed what were
you doing it I don't know I just love
that picture
that's that's like that's like just
giving everything yeah that's right you
gave everything you had right there
shaved head all [ __ ] up cuz you um
tried that you know that that Bud Light
that looks like that was after I beat
Gabriel Gonzaga look at your face god
damn it
sexy bastard oh no we're just getting
[ __ ] punched and just get cut off
oh I don't know I keep looking at this
not great
yeah just like dick dude I like that
picture ah hey your ear was a little bit
normal there nope that's that's that's
this one same [ __ ]
Oh your friend dude yeah you know your
friend ran in Tia dental we ran into
your enemy with his little bug Jelena
you saw you saw yours you know [ __ ]
cute she does video mean him hiking yeah
it's great it's cute as [ __ ] he's so
tough
he's so cute um it's got some speed huh
playing soccer
oh yeah yeah put him in the with the
eight girls with the older kids that's
how I started laughing sorry
he's got he grew up and felt so much
better we got big as myth his hands are
choice his hands are huge dude did you
see I posted this the Tyson Fury and it
calls his dad after the Beast won his
career no play this
right it was the best I've ever ever
seen in my life you couldn't you
couldn't write it you've done it you and
you're equal mama dollies for your
cheapness but let me tell you something
was some performance I'm still shaking
and they great
listen tech you can't move your song
well done
tech domestic air god bless you thank
you very nice that's a great - is that
great Mary Ellen mark Mary Mark Maret ha
you're coming early huh
you know sometimes talking to your
friend when you have problems just isn't
enough and you need a counselor a
licensed professional and you can start
communicating with a professional in
under 24 hours this is not a crisis line
it's not self-help it's professional
counseling done securely online I'm
talking about better help this they
basically have a broad range of
expertise they've got a counselors
network which may or may not be locally
available in many areas but the services
available to clients worldwide so you
can just log in to your account at any
time send a message to your counselor
and you get timely results thoughtful
responses all the time you can schedule
a weekly video or phone sessions this
isn't like where you have to wait in a
therapy office and then go in there
because a lot of times you don't have
time for that and you need to talk to
somebody faster than they can schedule
it so better help is there to help you
out they make great therapeutic matches
and you can even change counselors if
the one you're working with doesn't you
know feel like it's good so it's by the
way it's more affordable than
traditional offline counseling because
and oh and here's the cool part
financial aid is available so better
help.com slash reviews you can
see how good it is and you can get a
sense of what it's about before you
commit but when you're ready gonna
better help calm slash kid that's better
help Aichi LP / kid and join over
700,000 people taking charge of their
mental health with the help of
experienced professionals better
help.com / kids there's a special offer
for the fighter and the kid listeners
you get 10% off your first month that
better help calm / kid if you've got
student loan I do well that's what keeps
people in debt for kind of ever guess
what earnest can save you money
lower your monthly payment takes two
minutes check your rate online a little
financial relief goes a long way for a
lot of people student loans refinance
with earnt refinancing with earnest can
help you just don't sit back and think
bernie sanders get a win you know he's
gonna take away just do it alone well
guess what you're wrong you're wrong
we got some that really worked you can
pick a monthly payment to fit your
budget so you can breathe easy today mmm
cuz life is unpredictable you get things
that go on it's crazy it affect your
bank account you want to get out of debt
sooner earnest loan refinancing has the
solutions for you check in your rate is
fast and easy to start complete a few
questions online it only takes two
minutes and then you get personalized
rate estimates all without affecting
your credit score if you are if you
refinance alone it's no problem you can
still be eligible lower your interest
rate we got you babe hey our listeners
get a hundred hours cash bonus when you
refinance a student loan at earnest calm
/ fighter that's a hundred dollars cash
bonus when you refinance a student loan
earnest calm / fighter go to earnest
calm / fighter today terms conditions
apply mark looks like a goddamn
carpenter and I like it well I mean it's
a part it's an illusion
well you look you look half rabbi half
carpenter I know that I'm home for
aesthetics exactly don't go what happen
in that couch break he tackles me yeah
tackled me know and no like this well
you did you guys ever stop with their
like a her
oh no I didn't see I didn't want this I
don't want to do some big fan of yours I
love you Marcus I know you don't like
bullies and sports and stuff I turn one
guy who does these are people out there
that love bullies I know but you know II
like you think you've really played
sports as a bully and I wasn't man I'm
kicking it off like I don't think so
yeah I don't I don't think that everyone
who's in sports was a boy I know Brian
was yeah Brian was a big bully of course
I mean but he says he wasn't he was
actually bullied big enough to be a
bully yeah I'm not even gonna sound guys
yeah
and you could bully a guy like him too
well I'm a nice guy but a big guy and
then you could just yeah I slapped his
face sometimes I poke the bear to money
how I poke a bear too much and then he
gets mad and then he beats me does he
yeah come on well okay can you beat it
boy what's your martial art uh well now
just a peloton bike but it used to be
boxing judges oh yeah
boxing yeah he were fought in the UFC do
we have to hash my athletic achievement
you fought in the UFC yeah that ten ten
years have been crazy
I watched a little bit a little bit of
it the other day it's too much no I mean
I understand how it can make people
excited yeah yeah but like and I
understand how you could think that that
that there's a it's important yeah I
feel like you're searching how you can
see how some people could see how that
like that important but no I couldn't
let it
why don't you know there's a lot energy
going in I'll run in there watch any
sports they'll mark I don't man and it's
really not because I have anything
against sports I don't have the my
attention span I want to get to the
let's win already do you know what I'm I
don't have a lot of patience that's
better do you know what I mean like it I
imagine if I let myself something like
UFC would probably be pretty good for me
because each round you know something
someone's going down but then the
problem with that stuff is if like if
both of them end up standing you know
gives a [ __ ] like if you don't mean like
you could invest an hour and it's like
no one went down
what did what I just do yeah you know so
you know I don't and baseball's too long
for
I don't know it takes so it everything
takes too long your well the only guys
you and Chris D'Elia are the only two I
know that don't what ever watch any
sports
daliyah's like it doesn't matter yeah a
friend of mine when I was working here
no Frank Santorelli from Boston now meet
him when I did short attention span on
Comedy Central he was sort of he was on
the show of me he's my sidekick in away
and he was all excited about Super Bowl
II so he even watched him like no I
don't watch any sports I don't want you
football he goes he just looked at me
like complete earnestness and goes then
then how do you feel alive like you know
he couldn't it's just a grow up in a
certain light culture like that it's
like it's communal right so that's
communal it's competitive
oh that's a great guy oh he's great
funny [ __ ] dude he is funny yeah
great guy yeah but yeah I mean I played
a little when I was younger you know
minor league stuff yesterday day okay I
get a ball streets of Albuquerque
yeah streets Albuquerque no I did did
some literally did some swimming did you
in tennis did you up in Albuquerque I
grew up in Albuquerque I didn't know
that wow yeah a very tough town boy born
in Jersey my my folks moved to Alaska
for two years 69 71 dad was in the
military you were how old then well I
was like 63 so I was like 8 I by the
time I got to Albuquerque I was to nine
well so we are so I can grade big you
through high school al-bakr so I've
spent some time in Albuquerque Jeff you
spent a lot of time spent a lot of time
there taught me then it's I mean did you
do comedy it's a rough last year was it
the casino there oh right there would
see now that she was there when I was
younger you know it was rough but it was
a different kind of rough when I was a
kid like it was not it always had from
my recollection a pretty high violence a
rape or fighting but there was not there
was not the meth thing and there was
still some middle class to the place you
know there was still some industry like
it was still sort of a growing town yeah
when I grew up but there were but it was
motor with 60% Latino did you pass for
Latino cuz you got you look like not
really know
know what that mug moustache mark
maroney's you and Marc Mero no no I had
a jew-fro and I was old chubbier and I
didn't pass for anything but you know it
was it never occurred to me that it was
you know like there was more of them or
that do we were separate or whatever it
was just a town though it was just well
yep there's guns and stuff around cuz
there's the gun control laws are very
lacks there so I saw my first gun in in
in high school a guy showed me his gun
yeah but this is before gang [ __ ] really
it was I was there when it moved from
like disco to cholo like I was there for
you know the platform shoes and the
steel waste to leather jackets and then
it just shifted to flannel shirts
hunting shirts you know bandanas yeah
everything changed that you were there
you were there for the disco era the
Albuquerque discovered how could I think
of like oh yeah I think well it's the
mixed martial arts gym capital of
nothing I know nothing I was there I
think green chili green chili of soft
people and tough Mexican men yeah green
chile definitely tougher Mexican dudes
yeah but like you know if when I grew up
there was really I never sensed the
separation you know there was always
Chavez Gonzalez and you know and all the
names but they we were just all together
I ever sent friends did you did you
start comedy in Albuquerque not really
hope it has anyway killer how do you
came out of Albuquerque dude Brian
he was New York Jewish intellectual no
my my people were Jersey so I was make
sense I high school in Albuquerque and
then I went to college in Boston outside
of Boston first I went to a place called
Curry College it was for unmotivated
problem upper middle class Jewish guys
and dyslexic kids to get ya kit Rydia
you know liberal arts college in Milton
and I transferred to be you oh yeah it's
meant to be oh yeah I did five years
undergrad five years last year was slow
a lot of drinking right study I was in
English Lit major and I minored in film
studies cop of that minor together
through the art
history department I always feel like
you and I in a way I came to success
later than a lot of people in this
business
yeah I'm still coming for me I yeah yeah
get out of here okay here's the here's
the other thing when we write the Brian
yeah but when we talk about success it's
like your podcast has been big for how
long like you're one of the godfathers
hate that you know well I hate when the
way it worked was when I started it I
think it was before the only ones around
is before Joe was before Hardwick it was
it was like the only ones with Kevin
Smith had his thing going Corolla had a
thing going jimmy pardo had his thing
going jimmy dore had a thing go and
these are comics I know so the landscape
was very limited it was nothing really
the pods got landscape so this was
podcast landscape 2009 so then at the
beginning know what we know what the
hell did do how to get audience so you
we and we know how to make money so
there was a period there where we were
offering free [ __ ] you donated we'd send
you some stickers and a t-shirt we had
tiers of contributions and and we had
one advertiser was uh Adam and Eve yeah
I remember we're out of sex toys a lot
of flesh light but yeah I didn't do
flesh oh yeah I got a hot about the
Amazon they click early on yeah yeah I
didn't do the Amazon link thing either
but what started to happen was because
of the guest you know I started giving
traction and other press and then it
kind of built from there but I don't
think it became like I'm trying to
remember what year my producer actually
came on full-time to where we both could
make a living were you doing it all by
yourself out of your garage from the
yeah but my partner business partner
Brendan McDonald is my producer it has
been since I was on radio oh damn uh you
have known him since he's 23 you all
said credibility like you've had ability
as a comic when I started comedy I a
hundred percent so when I remember in
and this is 25 years ago think about
Jude 25 years ago I remember you we were
doing our rebar I died cited [ __ ]
energy here yeah terrified so I'd get so
prepared yeah I do my 10 minutes and
it'd be the highlight of my you know
it's like when you start now that's my
ladies one of those guys where I was
like is he a comic or what is he where
is he what is he doing
where'd he come from yeah actor what
it was both I was like where'd that guy
come from curly hair blonde guy jumping
around that's what I would do because I
didn't have the wit
I just might the knock on me for y'all
to mentum you're good at performance
you're not good at material right I
didn't have depth you weren't right no
wait don't written up in the New York
Times is like painfully funny I remember
there's an arc line and I'm like [ __ ]
20 years ago she helped painfully funny
but marked you you were a dork at the
store right that was the door guys a lot
of people forget you're a door guy
oh yeah but here's the figure Bryan was
like he the thing that happened with you
though is that you actually became a
character like you know you would do
your thing and you're always energetic
and great to watch but as life chipped
away at you you actually became hit
shift right shift man one time he and
Brennan asked me one time on this
podcast not not less than six years ago
why do you think you never quite made it
beyond I said the other side I was never
fully committed to anything right that's
the problem is those guys that was the
liability of the actors getting in is
that like they didn't really want to
live the life be the comic but they
wanted to get visibility and then all of
a sudden when that doesn't work out and
they're stuck being a comic then they've
really got have realized well when I
would think about getting a job as an
actor I swear to god this is true and
I've never said this publicly I wasn't
thinking about the work I got to do like
the deeper I stick work hey I swear to
God I was thinking about the the wine I
could order at a restaurant without
worrying about price lot of dudes do
everything for girls like musicians
comics I just never really my I like
girls but that was I never thought like
I'm gonna get on stage and be me and
chicks are gonna be like that's the guy
never ever occurred this might be why
you also are not paying alimony and all
kinds of I mean you've stayed married
twice I just didn't have do you not know
me no more twice yeah I've been married
twice the joke ideas I've been married
twice and I have no kids that's the kind
of [ __ ] I was
yeah I have two wives no kids and I say
who says my up I think my second wife
put it like this you think of bringing
children into this I'm so that was so
yeah I was a door guy at the store in 87
I graduate college you know had a pretty
good you know coke habit going I thought
it was really Kings would you know the
coke habit we're at the store right cuz
you're runnin with when I was in college
ease to do blow you know and it was but
I wasn't like out of control but it was
a thing I like or to have a habit
college or have the money why I just
kept borrowing money for my folks and
selling things hell yeah yeah but and
then eventually they find out it's not
good yeah but yeah it's hard to have a
real habit and I was never I was never a
heroin guy another but when I got I
graduated college and then that summer I
got [ __ ] up for about three months at
home ran around but I'd already done a
little bit of comedy I try you know I'd
done a bit when I was in college some
open mikes here and there around Boston
around Boston I would say the there was
a guy in in Albuquerque that used to
book comedies name was Ron Correa and he
used to do comedy nights at the
Chinatown restaurant on Central and you
know there was sort of a scene that
before the coast and then there was
laughs comedy club in Albuquerque later
yeah I don't think it's everything I
know it's not there anymore but anyways
so after college I [ __ ] around in
Albuquerque then I come to LA and I get
here I go live in Culver City with my
friend Steve Brill who I went to college
with that I wrote a play with in college
he's a director you know that guy
director why the Adam Sandler movies Oh
director Chen words last special yeah
directing a little Nicky and water boy I
think in like a six yeah yeah Jesus yeah
but he was my college that's him yeah
and I don't think we wrote together in
college and then we had a falling out
and then I moved out here with him in
Culver City to write a screenplay which
we did but I we couldn't stand each
other and then Pete Berg who I just
interviewed he was buddies with him and
he moved into the Culver City apartment
pushed me out but I here's the deal
I had auditioned right when I got here I
auditioned the Comedy Store I did like
an open mic with was that guy who
historic The Improv Howard Howard Howard
maybe I don't remember but I did those
auditions right and then I go right with
Steve I think nothing came of the
auditions or nothing and then I start to
do PA work I meet some people to get me
into the PA circuit so I can do that and
one of my first jobs one was working at
4a Kidsongs video I was out the circus
Vargas which was parked just dealing
with the I tell funny story about how
like this is like you know Tiger [ __ ]
and clowns and they're shooting kids and
everyone's on blow the directors on blow
and everything and they're the clowns
from the circus Vargas they're like you
wanna get high and I'm like yeah so we
go back to their trailer and worried
about to smoke a joint and I literally
had to say like you guys got to take off
the makeup are you but here's what
happens the second PA gig I got was on a
thing that mitya was producing oh she
did this myth they sure from Communists
yeah she was gonna do this big comedy
channel thing she's doing all these bits
had all written all the weirdos were
involved and I was I was just hired as a
PA and like she's [ __ ] Danny stone at
that point he's all sweaty and this
sharkskin jacket and weird and you know
duh what she's been kind of hot right
back then well this is 1987 I mean it's
starting to go oh yeah see that it was
there young it's great looking yeah and
she still had all her marbles but she
was slowing down a little bit he'll walk
around in her feather boa and [ __ ] and
it was like it's so weird the wiring no
would have been that more where the star
is exactly that one that's yeah around
man sexy though ya know for sure but
yeah so anyways so I get this a gig take
it easy
yeah I talked to Jimmy Scheuer about
that you say like I had a pager on my
dick so but anyways so I get this gig
look at that that's way back i
interviewed all those guys no I didn't
really I think that interview braver
those in Renault
right that's Billy braver and Leno and
on the right is that Lenny shulte sir
yeah I don't know who's on the right
jeez
but anyways Wow so I'm doing the thing
I'm doing that the PA job and I see
Mitzi and I stepped in I'm like do you
remember me man I auditioned for you
like six weeks ago two months ago do you
remember me
and she goes oh yeah yeah funny contact
a backer you can be a doorman so oh well
I didn't know what that meant so I'm so
[ __ ] excited right here I go to Mike
Becker who was their assistant and I got
just miss he just said I'm cool I can be
the door guy and he made me the head
doorman like immediately and I thought
that was a big deal you had to be a
comic to be a doorman but big deal but
the head doorman no stunk because you
got to schedule the other [ __ ] and
they're all comics a man back then there
was a she had a dumb little Comedy Store
Universal and there was one I mean I had
a schedule those too and I could make
sure everyone had their shirts and their
jackets and [ __ ] and had then the place
was so mismanaged there was that
payphone in the back of all that Ralphy
used to sit there there was the back
door guy would you get tugged so that
was the deal was you did all that then
you get time at the end of the night
well you were non paid regular so the
way nobody work or the Comedy Store
right yeah I know it was okay then it
was before it went under no it was good
but you know you kind of hustle the
tables in the main room the main room
shows they would do like two and night
to a night on weekends maybe three and
they'd sell real good it wasn't dead yet
okay but the deal was an on pay regular
so you could work in the belly room the
belly room was done on pay regular room
and certain non pay regulars and door
guys would have host shows up there but
you couldn't really you have to pull
people out of the other rooms to get an
audience up there tell people so if a
main room show broke you kind of run
around going more comedy and you drag
them upstairs yeah and do it that way
and occasionally you get thrown on in
the ORF if they had nobody yeah but that
was the way that worked called the grime
it's called a grind and a hustling yeah
that guy and now I was like she put I
moved out of Culver City cuz I was such
a that's it's tragic the whole [ __ ]
story was [ __ ] and ridiculous
yeah well I got living with Steve and
then Pete Berg moves in he's a [ __ ]
is another alpha monster like you guys
yeah and their [ __ ] give me a hard
time I'm sleeping on the couch and
they're bringing chicks home and they
wake me up because they want to use the
living room
and I'm just sitting there like a loser
my boxers wrapped in a blanket
hey al-bakr where am I gonna go to relax
yeah what a coach Albuquerque yeah but
then that like so I got to move out and
they there's a Steve's uncle owned the
building there's someone kicked down the
hall that needed a roommate right and
there it's just like down the hall and I
meet her and I move in there like within
a week you know I drank all the booze I
tried to [ __ ] her and there was like
there was an intervention is it
intervention like her boyfriend came in
and all the people she knew and like I
she was off drugs I got her on the blow
and we were making out and stuff and
they basically she had everything she
everyone she knew came in and threw me
out of the apartment and then and then
Mitzi let me live in Crest Ville that's
when I moved into Creston that's been a
nice move with your [ __ ]
your [ __ ] and like I wanted for that
with a bandanna like basically I like
for milk crates in a futon and I just
took like threw him on the floor and
dices old room and pres still y'all just
say who else was livable Freston when I
was there I had the good room it was a
Tamayo
lived upstairs to my old Sookie who used
to go out with Sam with the sound guy
Todd lived there and then Todd Lema SH
that Todd tha Todd he moved in and then
later Schubert moved in for a while
Nancy Redmond lived there for a while
that was cookie who was Nancy Redmond oh
look her up
Nancy Redmon's her pictures at the store
she was like this almost like I think
she was mentally challenged a little I
don't know what happens to some of these
comics like where do they go I wonder
that's Ned's he read she's still going
looks like she's still at it but she was
just sort of like this nice guy's weird
Jewish lady act she did kind of a nerdy
thing that's more look like her on that
video up there that was sort of more
when I knew her yeah so she lived up
there and she had this obese boyfriend
who used to live in New York that would
come out just huge
oh and but like least it but that's who
I guess it
whenever I hate talking with his one of
the things that I always been a very
positive upbeat guy just naturally my
serotonin was a probably bout at an 8 mm
and and I'm just lucky
and the comedy were the comedy world
member the New York Comedy Club in New
York City the comments like if she
probably that hey lady
it was just man and the Comedy Store
when I first started it was so dark and
heavy with characters like that and he'd
just be like I want to be the [ __ ] dude
what yeah it was you when I was working
the doorman it wasn't so much dark it
was just sort of like wait you it was a
real education because all those [ __ ]
pictures you see in the hallway I saw a
lot of those people oh yeah oh yeah
because all the people you're going what
the [ __ ] is that guy I saw him you're
still around like I would work the main
room door and you have Joey came in on
Jan heart a Karen Hebert who would Nancy
Ladd man who's still around Damon Wayans
dice Kenaston but there was still these
other ones like Larry score on Oh
there were dudes from that you don't
know anymore no no that funny
we ran into scar on oh and like Phil
year somewhere was really what year was
the strike when all that was 73 dude I
was there in 87 so you miss all that
yeah but there was some of those dudes
still around look at that more in that
shirt right now what's going on with
glow are you doing a glow right you're
doing a bunch too over there I just did
the I was just at the H&R meeting
apparently I'm not allowed to take my
dick out or touch people I was just
telling Brennan about it watching old
episodes of Entourage yeah where where I
watched five episodes the [ __ ] that was
being done and being said compared to
now with the me to movement you you it's
almost like I was watching it it was
almost like um it's almost like back in
the day when nobody was talking about
slavery but slavery was around like yeah
literally I was like the horn you hear
how you're talking about these women and
what would happen to you today like it
was just it's just a different world it
ten years ago I didn't even know those
also show based off a group of dude
right with a rattle
worse kind of dudes yeah it's like this
way it's kind of like this douchey I
know guys like that use of my friends
some are good guys I don't ever hang out
with guys no I couldn't actually I
watched it I go I never wanted yeah yeah
yeah you could for a little watch now
you get away Jake's what that's always
the question right are the chicks like
Bret Ernst is it broccoli over there by
Mary predator Lockley right is that what
he called a lot of broccoli over you
know it's like you know I hear this
complaint a lot but like I did some dude
my special drops I don't know we live
now oh yeah this would go up today yeah
well uh let's address some all right
right you know and I talk about the the
woke thing and I talk it's like I don't
know you know it doesn't seem to me that
the stuff that we should be aware of now
is bad stuff do you know what I mean
it's like that we're not there's no
censorship no one's saying you can't say
some no you can say whatever you want he
might just take a hit and before you say
my kind of might might want to go I just
worth it you know is it like is it worth
it you know if that's not a bad thing
not I mean the bit I doing the special
is like I say I'm about 85% woke and the
other and the other 15 I keep to myself
I really do not the biggest shift and
it's sort of like the right attitude is
sort of like and we had it coming it's
about [ __ ] time so so fair
yeah it's fair and fair and I think the
real problem with some dudes is just
that you can't what's that
but just know that's what a month ago a
beautiful it's tomorrow and what what's
a call it's called end times fun end
like the end times your second third
area please I think it's my second I did
I did one on Netflix than I did well not
know it's my third my third on Netflix
but I did one way at the beginning in
Netflix
thinkI pain was on Netflix and then more
later was on epics and then two real was
on Netflix and this one end times fun
what originally was titled jeremiad and
Robbie over at Netflix is like no one's
gonna know what that is
they're not gonna think that's funny you
gotta have a good but wait so go on keep
going about about the wrong thing oh
just it like Oh empathy is it men are
not naturally empathetic to women
because we don't live in there that's in
their world and most of us aren't even
empathetic to men because we're selfish
[ __ ] yeah so we assume that all dudes
are kind of like us but but to learn
empathy if you if you really are able to
sort of listen and open your mind up to
what women go through on a day-to-day
basis there's no way you can argue with
what's happening right now and and and
if you argue arguing with it it's only
because you were incapable of
empathizing with one well mainly also
though I was and that bursary signaling
that I was real know and also watching
the show I went I went I was completely
ignorant to just how bad it was all
because I'm not a woman and because the
way they would speak on the show was
funny and excited and it made the show
popular if you listen to how they're
talking it's like at one point one of
the guys goes in the office goes is my
assistant hot thinking about hitting her
hitting it or maybe I should fire I'm
out to sexually harass her until she
quits yeah that was the stuff that was
said and we move on today you have to
that have to be a huge thing three four
years ago or whenever that show was ten
years ago house ten years ago you go
he's it was just kind and funny and
normal we didn't think about it that I
think that was the problem is that would
it was normalized it was
institutionalized and it was the way
things were I think women sort of
accepted that until they didn't yes and
now that I work till it became rape
right and working in the business now
what I noticed is that for the first
time because for my entire career if you
are a woman and you keep playing I'll do
it what's asked keep your head down keep
your head down no but it's not even that
in compliment for the longest time in in
in the business if you complain as a
woman fine go ahead but you're not gonna
work again because there's a lot there's
a male whisperer network for the first
time there's a female whisperer network
that's kind of like now women go hey
this guy's a [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah it's
good but also it went super EXTREME
always has to go like you can even say
hey guys
yeah well yeah yeah it went for you just
went you know it was there was a them
out even out where it's like I don't be
a dick yeah because I think the
revolutionaries are always extreme no
mark
no I think you got there was a it got
hit a breaking point where where was
like all right we can finally talk and
these people are gonna go down and now
like the bad guys are out yeah but
they're out but they're still around
that's gonna keep happening a bit yeah I
do think it's it's not I don't even I'd
be wary to call it a correction but but
you know it needed to go as far as it as
it did in order for people to be aware
for all of us to be a little scared but
also to self check ourselves yeah and
change our behavior if Nettie fighters
sometimes just being being aware that's
all I realize we've all I say that
there's like there's a spectrum of male
toxicity and that and it goes from sort
of like this basic insensitivity and
lack of respect to murder you know and I
think great arc right but I think all
men sort of fall somewhere in there and
you just got to figure out where you are
and own it and change your [ __ ]
behavior I mean look if you can't do
comedy without saying [ __ ] you've got a
problem correct interview if it's like
if you're hung up and like what we can't
say [ __ ] anymore and that's a hinge of
your success of a comic question nothing
right yeah that's the best but what
would you say is the most what's that
what's the one complaint you've always
got you're gonna shake on context I just
wanna you can take that concert great
word throw a [ __ ] out there yeah canta
great word see I used to defend like
that by saying like I like saying I like
on dudes [ __ ] yeah but yeah then women
are sort of like but it still implies
there's something wrong with it being a
[ __ ] if you lost rally that's all they
say I know in England too [ __ ] [ __ ]
means you're your weak economy I know
but that's the [ __ ] up thing we grew
up with [ __ ] can't [ __ ] and it's
right in fact you get the fact
oh yeah but like yeah of course right
but uh but you know it's just like
another word they use an entourage a lot
but people don't say Chinamen anymore
you can make the shift
no one says coloured well it's like you
can all it's not hard to make the shift
no I don't need those words
these people feel bad I don't want to
use them anybody hurts people it hurts
people yeah I like I tried to continue
to use the word worse because that was
sort of a high-bred
the flood word was it was worse hands
ian was right together like wimp and
pushed together but it's worse so it's
not it was good it was I don't call
women honey or any of the Iowa I call
woman's sister I'll call them sister
I know an actor who calls women goddess
he goes thanks goddess wow thank you
lady what a nice thank you lady thanks
lady lady lady lady I say milady
no I'll save milady I try to remember
names I work with [ __ ] 14 women dude
I'm on Glo so like that set was right at
the cusp of the me to thing and I'm like
I'm the only dude yeah that's what women
are pretty racy oh no it's great cuz I
before the first season I had to sit
away from them because I had to focus on
my [ __ ] when they get going like when 13
women in a circle like I got it I got to
him to remind my [ __ ] did you take
acting lessons and go through that whole
thing I studied a bit of acting at
different points in my life like I I
took acting in college for a year and
then I when I lived in San Francisco I
studied it what was the name of that
place which the chery chery Carlsen
what was that was the plan you know
especially when you were coming up the
lot of guys would do stand-up to get
sitcoms no what were your plans yeah
well no I think the idea was like if you
were a good stand-up that eventually
they'd build a show around you it wasn't
just to get a sitcom the plan was like
I'm gonna be a stand-up show and they're
gonna make a show around I had three
deals yeah me too but uh but but yeah I
took some acting but early on I realized
like I'm just gonna be a stand-up
because I can't hack it like I'd go into
auditions and [ __ ] and it's like I'm not
a TV actor and these these scripts are
terrible and there's guys you can do
this better than me and I you know I
don't know how to do this so I didn't I
didn't even have an agent for like a
decade like legit well didn't you start
the podcast because you were so fed up
with [ __ ] I started it because I was
going broke I was in the middle of a
divorce
and I was looking down the barrel at a
lifetime of B rooms and you know infamy
and no one knew who I was I couldn't
sell tickets I'd have been at at 20
years 25 years damn so like and I've
done some ray
I knew I was good at it so it was like
one of those things I was up against it
and I was about to lose my house and I'm
like I'm gonna do this Wow you know I
didn't know it was that bad it's pretty
bad I mean I stacked a little money
because I went back to Air America I did
this video show that was destined to
fail but you know they offered me I said
they'd offer me a deal and I said the
only way I can work do this deal as if
you pay my wife whatever it's gonna take
to stop this divorce and then they're
like how much Mike I need about 60 K up
front to stop that to take this job and
they gave it to me oh wow
yeah yeah yeah cuz the pockets I was
talking to someone they asked what makes
your pot do you why do you listen to men
and I said it's something with you
Howard Stern when you guys get big
guests in it's just like you can tell
like you've had some huge gassy on where
you're not like it's not like a fan boy
thing and it's just like a regular combo
you know yeah I think not that that I
would ask you that I want to know about
it's not you know it's not like a Jimmy
Kimmel brain yeah it's a real art we're
really good yeah well fundamentally like
I rely like - I'm sorry to interrupt
like the lunar DiCaprio and Brad Pitt
even though it wasn't in your studio
right he did it like at a project there
was no yeah was that they done an event
at the ArcLight it would like in a back
room yeah but this why it worked is Brad
Pitt's a fan of yeah Aaron yeah so you
could tell it made the Caprio kind of
like oh cool you know he is right right
so there's this cool that floor the only
way it would work there's a podcaster
he's like he was like he loves my show
Maron man and he'd watched it like two
or three times all of it over and over
again when he was trying to get sober
and [ __ ] like he likes seeing now he
liked the way I was so aggravated about
everything so he's a fan of the like my
short fuse and everything which was
fortunate because the my machine kept
[ __ ] hot during the interview and I'm
dealing with Leonardo and Brad and I
knew the only way would work I knew I
couldn't do what I do usually no way but
if something happened between us it
would be great and now of a sudden I'm
getting a buzz so I'm starting to freak
out about the machine you can tell
you're a little like yeah I'm like I'm
sorry and I'm trying to fix it whatever
and then towards the end like I just
lose my god
damn it and piss just like
here it is it was like so thrilled to
see me lose my [ __ ] for real but yeah
that sets the tone cuz he's like I love
man yeah I watch all of them I've milked
it a little bin DiCaprio's like you know
then he's like oh cool man yeah and
there's like a regular combo but over
time like I think of what happened at
the beginning was I really think that
the first like hundred episodes or so or
just me having famous people over to
talk about my problems and I think that
did Obama come to your garage yeah I did
yeah came to the garage I did did they
have security come no he just came over
in a rental yeah man couple weeks ahead
of time really yeah they and I was in
Hawaii I was on vacation which I wasn't
gonna change even for the [ __ ]
president oh it was so funny you should
the episode to really listen to is the
one after that called the president was
here which is me and my producer Brendan
talking about what we went through to
have the president and how crazy I was
because I had had this vacation booked
you know and the president thing
happened out of nowhere like we'd heard
a year or two before that he was
interested someone on his staff liked
and I'm like yeah right so then all of a
sudden it gets booked and it's like a
big deal but it's like right of like my
vacation and I was sort of like I'm not
gonna cancel my vacation no but but but
Brendan was like oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
guest of all time yeah I'm like am I
gonna lose my points I was really hung
up I'm losing the point you need a
friend actually take a flat hand and
slap your face before us you know what
bothered me about the this great podcast
what bothered me is you have to submit
questions to them to okay right no I
thought I thought you said you there
were certain things you couldn't bring
up no no they were what I off on them
yeah there was we didn't have to submit
that was the weird amazing thing about
him there was no submission of questions
and there was no and they didn't even
want final edit they sort of trusted him
and they trusted me what I had to do was
like how do I do the kind of interview
that I do so it was up to me to stay
away from politics as much as I could
because I think that was not I think
that was not what I do want the
politician yeah because then you're
gonna just get this guy who's gonna do
that yeah and you're gonna get in the
weeds and you know it's gonna get boring
so like it was I had to create questions
that would engage him personally about
him but you know there was [ __ ] that had
to be covered I mean but you know some
of that crazy [ __ ] just shot you
know five or six black people in that
church you know days before yeah there
was some stuff coming up on in the
Supreme Court that needed attention so
because my producers are [ __ ] genius
and you know politically adept you much
more than me we're able to structure the
beginning of the show around the current
things that we're going to be unfolding
and then get into the bulk of the
interview but also I just had an hour so
it's really how do I do what I do not
like I didn't have to give them anything
Wow and yet two weeks before they send
Secret Service guys over to figure out
how they're gonna secure the perimeter
what the guys on the roof and children
that was the funny thing is like because
Brendan my producer flew out to deal
with a class in Hawaii and yeah they're
trying to figure out where to put the
snipers right so so Brendan's in the
garage and they got the guys up top you
know jump in there like up here and
they're jumping on it Brendan said the
ceiling was coming in and he's like not
good not good
yeah please and not up there calm
believe so eventually we had to ask my
neighbor if we could put snipers on his
roof Wow
and he was thrilled he's retired it was
exciting he's of course yeah so that day
there's like a dozen Secret Service
there's about a dozen LAPD and then like
after everyone's there the two snipers
show up you know they're in uniform and
they're just like they just got the guns
with him stone-cold killer yeah and they
just walk up one I was like use the
bathroom like yeah yeah it was like
intense man and then they just go but
they take the taxpayer about two million
dollars just to you yeah yeah yeah but
the but you know in to my credit or to
their credit he was staying in Beverly
Hills us easy he could have stopped
traffic all the way through if they
drove the motorcade but he flew the
[ __ ] helicopter we did to the Rose
Bowl
oh I minutes from my house so I come on
my deck and the Secret Service guy he
says we'll give you a heads-up when he's
20 minutes out and then they see the
Ospreys and Air Force two or whatever
in the sky I'm gonna sleep he's close
he's right coming to see you nervous
mark yeah sure I was nervous because you
know ya know like I was sitting around
my house going what the [ __ ] do i do
what do I wear the president's coming
I'm like [ __ ] it I wear what I wear and
you wear my number how about that before
what I do I wore my shirt I sat around
just me and Brendan in the house you
know see so you could service out there
there's all set up everyone's all set up
and I'm just playing my guitar how it
been madigan if you're in a tuxedo
yeah right he showed up and what was
that he came out well the driveway was
tented you know and the they've cleared
the road so the motorcade coming all
these cars are going by and then he
stopped and there's like a dozen people
coming up the grunt drive I was told to
stand in from the garage ingredient and
there's all these people like you know
his staff we have we had to set up five
listening stations they were gonna
record it out on the deck that the White
House photographer and literally they're
all these people coming through the gate
and I don't see him and all of a sudden
what hand goes up he goes mark and
there's like mr. president right now and
right away he walks up he's like we're
gonna have a good time I'm like I don't
know I don't know man I don't know so
it's hit or miss it's yes but so he was
very very nervous that staff tired too
much just in my mind like very nice guy
earnest guy a great show it was good it
was good we leave it up there it's
evergreen you know what my favorite one
is I'm a fan boy first I cannot get a
copyright but the one where you have on
the Argos Hamilton oh yeah when he goes
deep in the comic I love the comedy
really I had a wait to do that dude I
don't wait years to do this an issue
right yeah he wouldn't do it and with
mitzi alive oh really
uh-huh why out of respect oh I
appreciate that
yeah yeah it was fast Fergus the class
act oh isn't it yeah it's definitely
something yeah he's a class act
it was good been him drunk you guys go
through the old comic store days I loved
it yeah why did you have Mitzi's license
I do I do have her driver's license she
found it on the floor now but you showed
Argos here the hell'd you get that
actually Letterman - and he's like I
think it crimes been committed
yeah but uh
that it's like what a character um Jesus
Christ I don't know like you know it's
like you when you see him at the store
you like he's his face is kind of blurry
but it's like that in the daytime too
yeah it's like it's like that's a
regular picture
Abby Lee when he looked it was all full
of hope and excitement before it all
went terribly huh I just saw him on
stage at the Laugh Factory he absolutely
murdered Bobby oh my he's good he's back
on top of it yeah yeah but yeah I've
been very diligent about chronicling the
history of the store with people I can
do it with yeah it's great I like you
know Tom's reason was another one I love
Tom to as probably one flower yeah yeah
and he talks about it and there's a
one-man show about it does any basis why
Frank's Paul bearer's Paul bearer's he
was a he prides himself on being the guy
that Frank never yelled at you had Leno
on yeah then without all the gun it's a
little difficult Jimmy Walker was great
I had LeBeau on and schubert but that's
a different generation from the
old-timers I had Richard Lewis Billy
braver up yeah yeah we did a Brian I did
a show together in Vegas huh and we were
gonna book our own open or say oh no
they the Orleans books its own openers
we have a guy he's been doing for 40
years yeah just I'm doing a walk in it's
Jimmy Walker I don't know who he is
right I have no idea who is and Gray's
delivery so he's not really speaking
with us at all and then his mind it boys
like handler comes up and goes uh Jimmy
Julian like to meet you guys so mean I'm
like okay we're the headliner sold-out
show so like okay cool
walk up dude he won't look kissing Angus
I've been doing comedy over 50 years and
they never heard of you - I never heard
of you guys and they tell me your names
and I went mine he did this longest
thing I ever heard he goes and I was
like
yikes and then he got a cellphone was
intended to call like Jay Leno and
Letterman he was actually very funny but
laughable for that I don't know him I
was like I was like what the [ __ ]
wrong this dude yeah he was huge huge
huge he was the biggest star in the
world that's what people tell me I died
it was a yeah dynomite and a good actor
man and and and could in that show it's
a crazy story that's a crazy podcast to
talk to him yeah he still like up until
I probably a few years ago he used to
have a thing hanging at the store asking
for jokes he paid for jokes Oh Stella
yeah to write juggle turn our show you
know this is 219 this is last year he
was a if you want if you want to sign 8
by 10 get him in the back if you want my
CD get in the back my Jesus What did he
say to you when you went to go did he
sell any Brandon when you talk in the
crowd when he was like that's my time
enjoy headliners listen if you want a CD
when I sign 8 by 10 and our Catholic
[ __ ] is it 1980 he went to shake your
hold and I went I want them to great set
you know legend years don't touch me
brother don't touch them I went oh okay
dude yeah all right man well he's crazy
that's a row some a little bit you know
I felt bad cuz I found out after what a
legend he was he's a little out of his
mind so good it was fun though yeah it's
story and people don't get they get
stranger as they get older they don't
for sure dude this [ __ ] business full
of lunatics
no thanks miss because like what do you
do man
like it's like and I've seen it with the
way you get how ok I think about it all
the time you know cuz we even guys of
our generation you know you we've seen
dudes go up like you know give back when
we started when they were getting the
deals in half a million dollars million
dollars they're dudes go up and then go
nowhere the fine times like but like
guys like Kevin and Bill they [ __ ]
rose from the ashes man and both those
guys got paid a lot of money to do
something that didn't pan out and they
went back to the drawing board
and they became huge Kevin Hart bill
Burke but then but yeah but then there
are other cats where it's like they just
tell they did they never I think it's
because they're they have to live with
that [ __ ] disappointing that delusion
of
wrapped their [ __ ] brain around the
dippin how they survive in these not
writing there's that but they also
haven't made the same time and
commitment investments that you
gentlemen have maybe or else they might
not be talented enough that's no one
wants to factor that [ __ ] in you know
you said you have to be delusional to do
this to begin with and just because you
can doesn't mean you're good at it every
[ __ ] idiot in the world is like I do
comedy do you though yeah so like it's
true too so like in no one's gonna fire
you yell if you give your whole career
is based on doing bringer shows
yeah I'm produced shows who's gonna tell
you it's over well there's a comic who's
been in the game for as long as I have
and he just it just has never hit and
and he just doesn't and I said to my
friend again I got I can't figure out
why such-and-such isn't and my buddy
really he was just one like I not that
bright not that talented and that was it
and I went is that it oh it's like
heartbeat it might not be for you just
yeah I mean everybody puns back in the
NFL that guy's never going to make me
laugh and that's how it is it's
sometimes a shoe but it's weird because
sometimes morons make it pretty big the
thing you're a little wild right what do
I write and then then they get found out
and then what's gonna happen I see them
rise to the top but sometimes it does
work for morons now of course it's not
the cream doesn't kind of do the job of
rice book smart morons can do they stay
they stay in their Lane they stay in a
very tight a no they well that's the aw
that's a understanding your limitations
yes right that's a sports thing or is
that just a life thing know your
limitations someone told me that years
ago I'm like wow yeah I know it's
[ __ ] well there's this thing you can
be anything you want to be no you can't
let you look at me right now no you can
tell you very honest um can't really
tell Mike be honest with yourself be
honest with you sighs where are you good
where you're not my father was great no
you're sure
my father was created that my father was
just like writing movie writing movies
and books may not be for you and you're
funny
my grandfather my Italian grandfather I
swear to God I did a musical at the
Neighborhood Playhouse yeah I sang and I
danced and by the way I can cut I could
kind of dance when I was 20 I'm sure you
bots and I jump through it all I could
jump and touch my
I could do the I could do the Russian
thing when you juncture there and touch
your toes over and off and he looked at
me and I got offstage and and he said
listen you're never gonna make it as a
singer you're never gonna make a living
but did you notice that everybody
laughed at you more than they laughed at
everybody else I said I think so he goes
comedy do compliment one of patty
Jenkins patty Jenkins the great patty
Jenkins dated her for nine years
when when I mean she said to me she was
Brian Brian you you have to stop trying
to be Christopher Walken and Robert De
Niro and Al Pacino your dad's lesser you
are not a deep brooding oh dude you are
a jackass be the funny yeah usually do
impressions of those guys I don't
celebrity series I know that's that a
lot of people think that's hacky and
you'd be right
the point is this yeah and and and that
was my that was my light my life safe
somebody said stop trying to be a man
stop trying to be all tough and be macho
beat your masculinity comes out of your
being an idiot yeah what time when I was
younger went back it was actually it
stitches in Boston you know I was back
around the time give it was before you
start before you knew me I must be 1988
or 89 it was background when Rogan
started I remember when Rogan started it
was that that era and I was like doing
my kind of aggressive confrontation okay
I remember doing this whole set and some
dude just walks up to me he goes why
comedy those are important moments in
your life they're important money I had
to take him in like what else is like oh
and then one time Carrie Hoffman came up
to me years after that when I was
working
Carroll was the owner of Stan of New
York the original owner of Stan Lee very
famous club and honored managed people
and anyone on to become a Sinatra and I
was a he did a great Sinatra personage
be so good that my father who loves
Sinatra offered to finance his first
album and then my father bailed on that
because he was probably so funny can't
even find a picture of him
they've Kerry Hoffman I very much areas
that mother [ __ ] always liked them
though
he was all right he was nice enough but
he was sort of like you know he had this
at it like get him off you know he I
don't know he came up to me I
they always stuck me on shitty spots cuz
he didn't like what I did really but he
knew I was doing something yeah and he
couldn't stop me that was the problem
these [ __ ] gatekeepers and in general
Joey no it's just that like you know
club owners you know if you didn't play
the game
whatever game they were playing you know
they had a lot of power over field yeah
and you know a lot of them were [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah but but he's to give me
bad spots on showcases for Letterman and
[ __ ] but like one time he came up to me
he goes he just said this to my face he
goes you know um your comedy isn't about
what you're doing anymore I'm like what
look at what do I even do with a cut
carryovers I can do an impression
occasionally if I don't think about it
too much
yeah but uh I be able to do it I've been
working on George he's got to get I
think Harry had a good high park my car
out in the lot it's my George C Scott's
a good Marc Maron doing Jersey Scott
close I'm close so much did you had a
you had Nick Nolte on right yeah that
was there I can't meet you it was it's
painful to get through I love his voice
it's alright no great discussion I'm
sick because his voice yeah it makes me
I don't it's like it's like Stevo if you
talk when Steve was talking it's like I
did him - it feels like a painful I did
it was like a pain oh he's hurting
himself the thing about the way I talk
about Nolte is sort of like his brain is
kind of like when it comes to stories
and information it's like a bingo cage
you know it's just kind of tumbling and
yeah you're gonna forget if you can
connect whatever comes out he's he's
been an actor he's been highly loved do
it oh no I was great I'm I got a great
interview yeah usually way to come over
he's kind of shrinking he's like yeah
he's one of he wanna one of the great
actor yes probably had some struggles
with some booze it was sober sober when
I did warrior with him he's the DA I
picked his brain like an old medicine
ball now there is that's not all T all
the time he he's awesome he so my
buddy's doing a movie with him they're
talking about the script yeah and he
looks them and he goes like this he's at
his house he
he bought where they recorded one of the
Eagles albums then I got then it burned
down but it was a hell of a house and we
did a reading in his house
and during the reading yeah yeah and I
thought he's gonna have muffled yeah but
he's always brilliant he's always one of
the great actors one of my favorites so
he's with that I think is my buddy gavin
o'connor and and i think and so he goes
like this he goes there there I haven't
meeting any goes you guys wants you guys
hungry
you want lunch and then go okay I don't
know and he goes okay I think this I
gotta run and he runs he goes you just
hearing with sprinklers and the
sprinklers hurt and he's dodging the
sprinklers and he runs to a plum tree
and grabs a bunch of plums puts him in
his shirt and comes running back and
he's all wet from the sprinklers and he
goes plums
he's such a [ __ ] eccentric and in
between takes when we when we did
warrior he would have his earphones on
and he'd be playing the guitar jammin
and then to himself a good electric
guitar but then he forgot the earphones
didn't work on one point he was playing
it's just doin he's not he's not he's
not a maestro right you know who I
became a huge fan of Martin laughter
Yatim I was uh Josh Brolin I was great I
love a man he's of Venice guy so you
know we write the Venice Gary act he my
favorite thing about that is he was just
starting to do avengers right that he
was like right anyway you know with the
with the yeah doing our little thing
yeah doing the Marvel would he take it
serious yeah he was great about it man
he was like you know he was very
disarming that motherfucker's tricky
yeah he was like I don't really like I
never know how much people know about me
or the show a lot of times they're
informed by publicists like maybe she'll
listen to an episode and they show up go
like I love the show and then we can
cite like the two most recent episodes
yeah but man that guy like I walked
outside he got out of his car and he
looked at me like I know you and I'm
like yeah and he was very charming and
it was great for you know is Mark asked
asked him at you know doing more of a
like you know a lot of actors frown upon
doing this kind of selling out he's like
no not really man I know he's cool back
he's a great house guys make so much
money so much money I just thought I'd
have cheetah lon today Don Cheadle is
that Brolin right there on the right
here
what look at that dude well did you see
you saw him as a cable see now like
Geoff Cowan when you look at that what's
your first thought ah I mean I can get
there right no I didn't take that guy
that's a strong thick dude that that'd
be a tough guy to fight in an elevator
yeah that's Christ now it was great so
big look what they did to Kumail they
made him you know he was on Doc
Sheppard's podcast armchair expert
talking about just a discipline yet to
go through wrong with Rob McElhenney
gotta be juice in a would be like yeah
we got I'm halfway do a pocket square
I'm hoping they go yeah I took this so
kids realize or listeners realize that
okay that's looking the vascularity on
the right arm do you tell me he's not
doing so athletes so he has it if he he
always tells it says that to me who
Robbie he's natural and Brendan looks at
me and goes hey Brian look at me right
now yeah no you definitely take a
performance the and drugs understand
with that [ __ ] veins
dude you see his body before yeah you
know he's got a Lhasa got a good frame
though but doesn't he but it could it
just be like creatine or no no no but
he's got a good blossom blossom Marvel
called mousse that kid Brennan where he
played Batman mix here's a [ __ ] ton of
steroids like I'm not judging him for it
I just want to say that's why they look
at that doughy Kumail it looks great man
he looks you know how much you weighed
there how much 153 pounds on the right
on the left so he's 155 on the right
okay really yes you watch that 155 see
now is Oh like as you guys know is that
you know now he's got to feed that
monster like now like you know to
maintain that thing oh do you gotta be
half as well that's what they talk about
three clauses like that so plainly like
the exhaust I have to eat and all that
man oh no forget that man forget that's
I mean that's is that your entire life
look good for him though I'm so
impressed of that transfer but yes but
does that but can you would you do that
mark yeah I'd like to try it
that lesson fortunately I have I did my
deadlift this morning some chest presses
did so [ __ ] I could see it when you
walked in yeah shooting it you have a
marshal yeah marshal power you know I
had a little back issue uh-huh cuz I cuz
I'm a [ __ ] [ __ ]
like I you know I've always worked out
you know for many years and but like I
[ __ ] my back up how by being a dummy
with the corona left a little more
know what it was is like you know I got
I was uh getting the curl bar I'm off
the machine like not the machine but on
the break of what do you call it the
rack yeah I put it on my on my back and
I laid it on the vertebra and I and I
pulled it off and there was a lot of
weight on there and I could hear the pop
Oh like so yeah so like I got a few
protrusions on a curl bar cause that's a
squat bar squat bar I'm sorry yes yeah
well I have to for the fans because I
know they're gonna go you [ __ ] does
no difference Quapaw in a curl bar and
if they didn't they do now I know what a
curl bar is that the one with the bendy
one yeah yeah no no this is a squat bar
but you can do curls with a squash
[ __ ] I was doing everything wrong that
whoever can make a goddamn thing man
[ __ ] yeah how much longer do we have you
yeah I just I'm worried about the cord
put a quarter in the meter sorry about
that I don't pay for your okay I get
tickets and I don't care you do yeah I
go like this 50 bucks but like right now
who's got a quarter I got one in my car
if I went it took three minutes to go
I'm gonna take you I'm gonna stay you're
pissed break alright put money in the
meter - what is it um what is your
special about them nutshell can you say
it or is it about a lot of things I deal
with well end times like the idea that
yeah the world is ending is sort of a
theme throughout it but but the like why
I deal with a lot of different stuff I
deal with some Paula takes some
supplements I deal with I deal with you
know fire I deal with the environmental
stuff I deal with what it was like back
in the day I deal but the last bit the
final bits great I do I talk about
Marvel the Marvel Universe
you know Jesus is involved Iron Man's
involved the Vice President is involved
you shoot at somebody is a big clothes
can't wait would you shoot that money
closer I shot here at the Red Cat it was
we were gonna do in Boston but then my
genius director Lynn Shelton could not
do a camera thing she wanted to do in
the old theatre there so we did it right
downtown and direct isn't there an issue
while you're shooting it wasn't didn't
something happen while you're shooting
it no it's really just moving the moving
of the venue yeah I mean how you know we
had to move it here and it's just a
black box here it was nice because we
could do whatever we wanted people what
does
the issue I have with the first crowd
was disappointing that's right and it
was nerve-racking that's right because
like I didn't really take into
consideration that a theater theater
like a black box theater not like an old
one like we're all used to vaudeville
sty 1890 early nineteen hundred's but a
black box here has a certain vibe to it
yeah it does and people go there with
that expectation like it's a you know a
low energy isn't it right the sound gets
absorbed right there
yeah tough theater cuz that the sound
gets absorbed it doesn't really
reverberate it's well it's also like
it's guy I don't know what if we made a
great set I mean if you look at pictures
of this set I don't know if you can find
them of the one we made you could see it
from that picture of a soldier he shot
to mark well that was the thing as the
first one was like I knew it was just
okay you know and it wasn't anyone's
fault it was seven o'clock on a Friday
that's not were go to the official
trailer really show riding right so like
I'm like after that first shot I was
like well this better [ __ ] be like
this is all I got to this one this is it
and it worked out he's like you know the
stakes were high but I'll tell you that
that opening here's what the set looks
like can show this right soon yes our
world ending environmental ease I think
you know all of us in our hearts really
know that we did everything we could you
know we really we really did we brought
our own bags
to the supermarket yeah that's about it
have to catch on fire with that do it
[ __ ] you guys should see how the set
looks oh yeah it's sweet ligaments
I can't wait to end there this guy
caught fire I think in India burned for
three days and it rained for like a
month burning Skies good for America
it should be recognized that the story
of Jesus and the Marvel Universe created
in Jewish writer rooms my husband of
Jewish creativity
keep making [ __ ] up that they like so
they don't kill us
you're [ __ ] great mark actually made
micro them of things you're pretty sure
you know and they made another column of
how you know those things most of that
column is like now some guy told me goes
into the box sounds good
I'm gonna tell other people that that's
how brand marketing works and also
fascism we're finding thanks use us yang
so smart I think you're the only guy
they can just chill on a stool neucom
bra
I was watching so hard I was watching
the in the main room I was on earlier
than you went on I was watching in the
in the main yeah and this is my favorite
thing to do when like veteran comics get
a cold yeah cuz I'm like ah I know you
have a bag of tricks yeah yeah I know
he's makes me real nervous I'm been
doing it as long and this guy there's
he's guy I don't know if you remember
this there there they be to your right
there sitting in the front in the main
room here and there are two Australians
fathering a son right and you say
something and the guys keep going to go
through what the what the [ __ ] man what
the [ __ ] man and they're not backing
down and I'm watching like yoga and the
guy stands up and then the security
comes I like security another four 300
400 pounds like the [ __ ] these guys
gonna do yeah and you and you you care
in doorman tearing them and then if the
crowds clapping like right yeah and then
you go oh [ __ ] man and it's my furious I
think I worry about walking my car I
don't want to do this but it is so great
man it was so heavy worried though kind
of like and then I say this one like the
door guys realized I was a fan yours cuz
they go I thought you were leaving I was
like I was going to but I don't and I
was like no districts right you guys I
don't think you're quick enough to get
to the stage if those guys got stairs
mark so I'm gonna hang here well one
time I was late you should see me I'm
trying the father and son from Australia
for whatever reason I've had the mark
goes in hard are they they weren't even
talking to me right there just being
yeah yeah yeah and you go what the [ __ ]
yeah yeah just if I'm in the wrong state
although from the stool yeah yeah yeah
that's the student you weren't you doing
standing what I'm in a girl goes ah you
can't talk about Jesus that way
really and then the the father her
father called next day and tried to sue
the club for defamation oh yeah what
that mean yeah yeah and you tell us
story but it was you were on stage
talking about I was so funny I remember
like wait yeah I remember like I
remember who was it somebody called the
cops on the ahmed somewhere oh yeah
that's right that's right yes I would
sit on a stool like a lot more Biostar
is a decision dude are you sure okay
well then I did not for you know I look
like a bear in a circus right like the
elephant stool it's distracting I made a
choice to do that years ago because like
I realized that there were guys and I
was that great comics who did it back in
the day yeah and you know and I was like
well what's really changed is is like
this need to you know you feel like you
knocking that people aren't gonna pay
attention but I found like Shelley
Berman or even like you know pre rape
Cosby that there was freeing that red
ripe awareness guy before we knew yeah
yeah like the idea of sitting down and
owning this it actually brings people in
it makes them engage I have another
different level of another three why
you're only guys can do it you have to
be such a powerful writer you have to be
such a good writers where your material
is so good and you're so good with your
words otherwise we don't have to get up
and do all this you know and get
people's attention yes so you can
activate people just with your voice
it's a real [ __ ] gift work right here
but I think it's also just like there's
it implies a confidence because I've
seen you know guys like doing that
aren't like you know Kravitz used to sit
down and you know he was a little you
know scattered and stuff but but there
is something about it changes the
dynamic of the conversation I don't know
if it's about the writing or anything
else but people listen to you a little
differently
Tony can't do it mark if you if you know
if you're writing wasn't [ __ ] some of
the bass right it's like if a guy who's
like a who's not a great writer sits
down on a stool people are gonna so
they're like well I think why is he what
he's not doing the work but the thing is
is like people were idiots like you know
people who separate comics like he's a
storyteller he's this or that it's like
a comedy is what
is funny it's like well yeah but
long-form comedies been around forever
you know I don't know where people get
these labels from alternative whatever
if you can [ __ ] make people laugh in
the main room on a [ __ ] Friday you're
doing a regular audience you can do the
job right thank you sir I always say
that I always say hold on our people
laugh and their ass off or are they not
and I think the difference with you in
the while says about bill burr too is
you guys are very good at being very
funny but also getting people to think
bill can do that - yeah you remind
people they'll different a lot of the
way we're living yes probably built on
out on a glass house right yeah I like
Bill gives you there's a the thing about
doing it that way is like Bill will
[ __ ] take a hit for five minutes
oh yeah leave some [ __ ] and sometimes
you gotta eat [ __ ] I do not like it but
it took me a long time to build the last
bit of this special and they put this
this is two years in the making this
yeah you toured it for two and then
Charlotte yeah toward it but like with
the way I work cuz I don't write on
paper like everything evolves on stage
so things were still happening you know
up to the week of the special naughty
guy that writes it all down on the
outline I don't rub it yellow points
yeah I like I like my things to have a
through-line I like all back so they
took a really go a long time to shape
the thing so everything kind of folds
back in on itself and the ending of the
thing the one thing I can say about this
special is like I can see all the work
I've done in my entire life as a comic
in that special like everything all the
tools I can see that guys who I'm paying
respect to yeah I can see who my heroes
are in this special like I know the
moments in retrospective like well this
is sort of me honoring that guy like I
feel all that stuff in this thing that's
a great thing a great thing to hear yeah
because the last bit is like something I
would have done in 2004 like when I was
really aggressive and kind of shocked
driven and provocative but now like I've
gotten a certain amount of confidence
and and self-esteem around stuff that I
just ease people into it it's like I
tell them I'm like this gonna hurt a
little bit it's an icy to her little
yeah and do this though it's a really
nice do it record of your life it's a
marker for your growth - yeah for sure
like it's like if you're not existent
kids are in and I'm still like just like
I always have and I made
a nod clothing decision like I see
though you know good because I can if
you're in a tuxedo I've been pissed no
Toxie you don't see those but like the
last special I wore this ugly flannel
shirt that had a hole in it and then I'm
looking at that I'm like the [ __ ] is
wrong with me can't I figure out what to
wear on television so I'm wearing these
boots I'm wearing these pants and jeans
but I bought the vest and the shirt in
life I like this but I don't know if
I'll ever wear it again yeah I like the
hood though looks like a nice tan it's
got that nice no collar shirt I'm gonna
wear up [ __ ] thanks buddy I'm gonna
start over those shoes I told the guy
who made the shoes that I wore his shoes
on there on the TV it's fantastical this
pants up rolled them up a great hipster
I like the roll-up look mark yeah I
don't usually do that see like I make
the decisions for big moments in my life
on television that will be captured
forever and then a lot of times like a
month later I'm like the [ __ ] was I
doing here yeah did you talk to uh
Joaquin Phoenix at all when you did the
job not really at the Joker a little bit
at the premiere but no that's right
you're the Joker yeah he was sort of in
it yeah I talked to DeNiro a bit did you
yeah
he didn't really talk to denier I heard
he was just still in character I just
saw I didn't he made an interesting
choice that I very much recognized and
and I in in the moment I I fought to not
take personally like he was doing his
thing and I got that and he was talking
to Todd Phillips that's that's the only
person he was really engages the
director and like I was there for like a
week and change because I'm I'm on the
set the entire last part of the movie
but like when I walk into that room for
that little beat there where you know
I'm saying like you in telling DeNiro
like he can't put him on like the
greenroom right yeah yeah is that to the
first take we did the first take
you know and Joaquin's you know
registering me talking to him but the
second take he chose not even to
acknowledge I was very interesting and
it was genius like it was really like
that's what he would do like once Murray
walks into that room for the first time
that Joaquin's seeing this guy Murray
like he just that's all hey and like I'm
talking to him he's not
look at him he's just focused on yeah
yeah what a beast I'm special dude you
guys didn't see each other on set right
you know I was saying I was in that old
carpet so you had the back of the head
moment I hope you see me in the in the
blurry mirror if you blur your eyes
sometimes it'll two negatives come up
with a positive you could see Bobby Lee
on the spot guys cuz dude when I saw
this much of your face oh my god did you
talk to him tanka boy he's a good buddy
no I mean - no no no he wouldn't even
but talk to extras come on exactly is he
wearing a vest okay but todd todd
cameras like ham sorry it's a small role
and i was like we did a whole walking
talk that he cut out like there's a
thing of me and DeNiro walking yeah up
to the dressing room they cut out and he
said look how skinny I was that [ __ ]
beautiful I gotta be careful not get too
skinny
you look fine thanks I wish I had that
problem hey was that a wig De Niro was
wearing it's not a wig no dear you oh
dear didn't look like it wait to me he
does do something with his mouth I don't
know what they were working on be seen
to do some teeth before each take he has
a person there I think you know he was
nice he talked to me a little bit he if
there's that great moment with the note
though like um oh but before I forget
that they so Tim Phillips cut the walk
and talk and he said look he he he
didn't wanna have anything in the movie
that wasn't that Joaquim wasn't it oh
wow I thought that movie was a master
because there's like an idea that is
this real is it not real so there's
nothing in the movie there's no scene
without Joaquin in it Wow look at that
picture yeah that's a good picture you
frame that cell for now you know Gavin
on my phone I wish I should frame it
here that would be my [ __ ] basement
blown up oh yeah maybe I will
yeah that's it that's a that's a
masterpiece that movie didn't you think
er what do you think of the movie I
thought that like you know there was a
couple of things I would have done
differently - it would have been better
I think if we sympathized with his
character more before he goes bad like I
think there was something odd about like
he like
who was a director my girlfriend she
said like if they just had one scene at
the beginning of the movie of him
actually entertaining children him being
north yeah that makes sense
do you know to wear heavy to me like it
was it was almost over over-the-top yeah
I left her just going like wow Jesus man
yeah like he's already bro dark yeah or
it would have been nice to see the
heartbreak that caused him to be the
month yeah that's a little bit yeah but
um but the moment was great because he
liked De Niro's a real pro you know
we're talking isn't no mean I'm sure he
wouldn't know me now to be honest with
you I don't you mean and you know it's
like how many guys like have done that
with it yes you know what I mean that
yeah
just his job but but here's the thing
like so the first take when we're doing
the walking talk I'm me you know I
always come always I'm waiting all day
to do the thing and so action and I'm my
grandmother and I'm doing the thing and
Todd goes cut and then I stop and see
the DeNiro walk over he sits down for a
second then he gets up he walks over the
Todd and then walks back with chair and
then Todd walks over to be and Todd goes
like you're coming in a little hot like
you know d0 saying right he's a Lynott's
he says you remember he's your boss you
know my car good know that [ __ ] but
DeNiro hands are like you're probably
not gonna tell me yeah he said that the
drunk is like I'm his boss right so he's
really do yelling before you don't I
mean yeah that's interesting
yeah well that's that's how you work
together he's um I always feel like when
you work with yeah when you work with De
Niro like the way you did I feel like
for him it would be like the way a
dentist sees that many patients they're
not gonna remember year later you don't
have it like there wasn't enough between
us for us to really dig in you know like
but but like all I'm a thing hey Mark at
your level do so does your agent call
you a hey we want you to audition or do
we just want you read for this odd love
stand-up comic so he knows yeah he
offered me it wasn't this party he
offered me actually the other part where
whatever when when he know he when the
the guy when the guy fires him all the
boss of the cloud yeah yeah he bruins a
sign he's like I really it like I let
you go
yeah yeah that was the one thing I read
for oh you're such manner yeah but then
he said I got this for you he said this
is I think this is better yeah I agree
but but the thing is is like you know I
couldn't really dig in with the narrow
so what my approach to it was like you
know just do your thing and don't like
the good thing about the podcast is like
I've met so many guys that are huge or
you know in there they're they're really
just people and they become people very
quickly for me it doesn't faze you
anymore yeah I've got something inside
me yeah you know like so you're just a
guy and in that it's really it's kind of
true of course correct you know so once
you got that in your head you can just
do your work have a very peculiar skill
and a particular skill but no struggle
but that's the weird thing you watch
this thing then I watched him me like he
couldn't get his lines completely and
like the other way you know and it was
all very fragmented but they know where
the cameras they know how it's gonna cut
and like you know I give it like
watching what was going on in the studio
and then watching the final cut I'm like
holy [ __ ] yeah that's the magic of these
dudes right they know exactly they know
what's gonna like yeah like who was at
Jeff Daniels said to me says you got to
learn how to what did how to use your
face Jeremy Piven was that way he taught
me that on Entourage he said he goes
look the way they're gonna edit this he
knew exactly how to edit you know
exactly and he he was directing me
quietly he was like that when you start
this to start this way otherwise they
won't use the tape everything the good
guy didn't do it so long yeah they just
it's all I have I have the time I don't
know what [ __ ] cameras on yeah I'm
like yeah I'm just in my clothes minute
it's still in it I do it every day I'm
like it's my close-up hour but I do have
this trick that I do now like I make a
joke about it with the wind and I did it
in it's too bad you can't isolate the
clip where I do this thing where I get
this when I'm walking away right after
the scenes over I do one of these like
you can say get the land yeah okay okay
okay get your face timing closure man
killed
seen ya buttoning the scene that's Marin
just button the scene right there yeah
there it is it's a book in a [ __ ] book
end of it yeah were you uh I'm sure he
learned all done doing shooting Marin
there was it three I knew that was it
was four seasons that I knew that was
that was my school like I got the gig I
knew that I was probably kind of sucked
the first season if I get the hang of it
and then as a went on I get more
comfortable without one and two are the
best seasons I do too
yeah probably I thought I loved the last
season because it was weird I love
really weird I love to relapse I like to
rehab yeah
and but like I knew over there a
learning curve to it but I'm getting
better now I'm like sort of like trying
to figure out like I'm noticing more
about acting where you're coming from
your intentions and [ __ ] you know what I
mean making those adjustments you're
making decisions like I still feel like
there's no engine for me to get better
yeah and I think I'm getting I always
just think about what I'm what am i
doing in the scene what is what I want
from the careful one we're bad with sort
of like especially when you're shooting
a show and you're shooting a to order at
a time sequence yeah we're like what was
happening right before this yeah that's
the trickiest thing for me to get yeah I
try to just break it down to that there
I go what do I want and what do I want
from this character what am I trying to
some of that's innate right you kind of
know it yeah but you got to put it in
the place but more like some you know
the world turns like if someone just
goes you're not as like you'reyou're
less hungry or whatever like you to play
that kind of stuff problem with it
that's a bad director sometimes
directors don't know how to speak to you
so what I'll do is I'll say something
like this gotta be happier well I don't
know even by happier give me this no no
give me so so what do you want me to do
to that person now if you said to me
scare that person charm that person
flirt right like those are good right
now now I have you're giving me
something tomato and he can throw a
little switch and yeah I'm gonna or have
you said um you know try to make them
laugh with that you know do something
different right now now I'm now you're
now you're gonna make me look happy yeah
when you say how would you in the world
would you ever play sexy and I going to
play sexy huh even when they say you
know try to seduce her I gave you better
off like you want her
yes yeah that's different because if you
were to say to me here's a good now you
want her but she doesn't yeah if you
said to me
seduce her I was I don't have more data
well that's what I described a direct
sale clearly look at her look at her
she's so beautiful
it should make you it should actually
make you look at her like you smell
something bad because she's so
good-looking that you're just like this
so you're my god you're going am I
getting to it oh yeah like what is your
name yeah yeah yeah stinks I can't right
now now you go this guy hi this guy
really likes her you know it so that a
good director can really help you
navigate a role by telling you what to
do yep yeah
and it felt Seymour Hoffman needs to do
that so he directed a lot of at the
labyrinth theater and when I talked to
the actors that is he was always saying
to his actors what are you what are you
doing here what are you trying to get
from the person that you're that's in
front of you what are you trying to get
from them what do you want from them you
want their attention you're trying to
teach them something or you try to
seduce them he kind of robbed them you
trying to live in them what are you
trying to do here you trying to get him
to love you you know he was always
asking that question and that'll help an
actor you don't have to have a lot of
class you just need a good director to
help you get there where I am right yeah
so yeah it's it's it's it's that's why
director that's why I'm Meryl Streep
Meryl Streep to me to me in many ways
the greatest actress ever
she said she was doing moonlit at
Shahnaz it was some [ __ ] play that
became a movie and she goes the director
kind of didn't direct her and she he
told her something it wasn't working and
she goes I've forgotten that act like
and she goes I don't know how to do this
and she went to the director she goes
I'm a terrible actor and the drags the
hole but everybody it needs an actor
sometimes you can't find your way
through everyone needs a director yeah
yeah just cuz you've done it a thousand
times it doesn't mean ideas a lot of
likes Tanner but I love about stand-up
is that just cuz you have ten specials
doesn't mean that your next special is
gonna be great
you still have to fight for it the same
way you did allow how to do this one
liked it so hard for me to to wrangle
that last bit and some of the stuff in
this new special like it's just
I just you just have to let it evolve
yes and like I passed I stopped some I
got I didn't put some stuff in like cuz
I had to cut it for time and I really
had to make some interesting just how
much time did you do like I was doing
about an hour 45 oh wow you know and
there was no way I knew it like you're
the last special it was weird how here's
how you know you [ __ ] our pro man
like going into my last special which if
they wanted 73 minutes it was like that
specific and the the two shows I did you
know like before i taked were an hour
and forty yeah and so the show before I
take the one right before I just wrote
down the [ __ ] and I took out everything
that didn't you know connect and I put
it in my head didn't take any notes out
there 75 minutes you know don't like I'm
like and it was like that is no weird
you know when I have a woman I have a
clock I can do that to a mint to the
minute I don't know how I do it like
I'll do an hour the other day I did an
hour and 45 onstage and then they said
they said bring it down and I said they
put a clock on there and I I could get
down to 60 or 65 yeah depending on the
audience that same hour to 45 it's like
is there an hour and 20 I'm like the
[ __ ] happened right I had too much work
yeah took too much to my words too many
you know whenever you talk we can get
the flow going a lot of times when
you're doing the long sets you get into
it like a more relaxed groove you can
push things a little further yes so then
there you you're not used to this
because the special airs tonight or
tomorrow tomorrow so then you're gonna
just work on material then go back
there's a lot of stuff like like what 75
minutes you didn't do right right
exactly it's like yeah I never think of
that I never think like I got to do a
new hour she just it's just sort of
happens every year and a half year and a
half you get tired of it don't mom yeah
so there's there's stuff that we're
definitely the seeds of things that I
didn't use and how many specials is this
for you the total including half hour
everything yes well it's the I did a
half hour and HBO 95 I did to Comedy
Central Presents
right so that's two half hours
and then I did not including records so
not including CDs right so I did I would
include CDs oh boy yeah where we at look
so in the CDs I think I've done can we
look somehow your ID be me I know I
could be on Netflix or on iTunes CDs
I've done one two three I think I've
done five CDs yeah right and I've done
what three half hour specials thinkI
pain more later too real and this one so
three half hours at twelve and for our
pluses that's twelve specials basically
yeah yeah someone's Jesus Christ like
four hours and then Fox LEDs plus
another one four and then thinkI pain
which was also on Netflix which is also
two of us yeah five hours six hours
right right this has to be funny that
was that [ __ ] night was crazy the one
when I recorded this has to be funny
2011 top right what was of the nightmare
because I like I was going out with a
lunatic right and it was crazy dude she
was driving me nuts and it was dangerous
and weird and she look like just a
mental problems and of course I was
locked in we're looking up with him I
tried to break up with I broke up with
her she would not leave my house she
didn't live in my house so literally the
day before I left for New York
I put her [ __ ] outside I've been there
Donna and I'm like I'm sorry but you got
to go and I had to leave the next
morning to go do that CD and be
interviewed by the New York Times of
Saudi WEF okay that was the big art
section piece on the podcast so I'm red
I'm getting texts during my interview or
the New York Times from her going like
I'm under your deck someone's called the
police
I'm outside right now and I'm like oh my
god all right it was just crazy and like
because I I had to you know I would
really had to call the police and and
tell her that she couldn't she had her
own way
crying but she had gone back to the
place how hot was she though I'll put up
with some [ __ ] that hot enough I just
was taken with her I thought she was
bright and exciting and funny and cute
she was legette and increase like I and
I kept the I never knew what a
codependent [ __ ] I was cuz I'm like
everyone around me was like you know no
one was saying nothing of course yeah
right don't interfere not your business
help and like and I just loved her and
after all that [ __ ] after everything
I went through to get to get her out of
the house and I was going to [ __ ]
al-anon meeting yes I was doing the
whole [ __ ] trip about four or five
months later it I just broke and I'm
like okay lunch yeah do it do it back
and then in like six months later I
asked her to marry me and then Marc
Maron yeah and then it just hit the wall
get idea was just sort of like one day
I'm like I'm done yeah now like I was on
the road and she didn't come home all
night yeah and we were in couples
therapy I'm trying to work this [ __ ] out
and then she admits why I'm like what oh
why the [ __ ] would you not come home
where were you she goes I think I did it
to [ __ ] you up and I'm like Oh calm out
Jeffrey Tambor the actor talks about how
he said he's dating this girl and he's
gonna just break up with her he's gonna
break up with her it's raining it's
raining it was out thin very light he's
meeting her at the end of the pier I
think with Santa Monica Pier he's
walking towards her nobody else down the
pier and he goes this is gonna be tough
but I'm gonna break up with her because
this is this is not good for me it's not
good for her and I'm gonna live my life
and this is obviously run its course and
everything else is she's standing there
and the rain is falling on her face and
she's beautiful hey thanks oh I'm gonna
break up with her here yeah it looks
there like that you stand there and he
goes and by the way I'm hearing and that
then got divorced because I go yeah I
chose you'll break up my longtime
girlfriend my dad goes dude in a public
place or should I make a scene you know
what you guys love PF Changs right oh
yeah like if just a PF Changs right
there you might be the worst breaker
upper two and you do it during a dinner
yeah would he also can
my father's out here so at the end you
take your PF Changs and we're are not so
nervous when I just do it but just pull
the band-aid off and I go I'll take the
chicken lettuce wrap you know this just
isn't yeah I can't do this yes why tell
you I hate I just it's just not working
she goes are you because are you
breaking up with writing no no no God no
no no stay with it for two more years
when I broke up with her I literally
like just itch I just hit this wall it
was right you know it was the day like
literally the day before I think or two
days before my 50th birthday and and I
just said look I'm done you you know you
can stay in the house as long as it
takes her to get out
you can keep the ring I'll pay for a
storage space for a year I'll give you
$10,000 I'm leaving what a great leaving
my job and I I started like I just
started staying at hotels from the hotel
app yeah in town
yeah so I'm just going from hotel to
hotel until she gets out of my house
yeah and I remember I was in a hotel in
[ __ ] West Hollywood on my 50th
birthday by myself and then Ryan singer
says let's go to Canter's for your
birthday I'm like all right dude so
that's what I did on my 50th birthday me
and Ryan singer Cigna counters that have
waiting for that [ __ ] person to get
out of my face now yeah she's not only
she'd get out she cleaned the place
which was the first time she ever did
that Wow this room that I had that she
had her own kind of room for [ __ ] and it
was just this mound of clothing garbage
and nail polish and she cleaned the
place immaculately and left a nice
little note
that's a nice send-off that's a nice
send-off it's like a little for a little
while
but didn't I just detached I was really
kind of done my girl took all my clothes
all my furniture and I mean all of it
and the bed I was sleeping and woke me
up that was good
really oh yeah and then without the
divorce was different I lost a lot more
on the divorce yeah this was like you
know this was I felt bad about it but
they're just like it just got too
Tyl too weird and you know when somebody
has a certain type of mental disposition
it's never gonna get better and I'm old
but what was the hold on mark I'm 56
is there a through-line to what women
complain to you about you because for me
it's not being present or considerate
like I'm too much in my own world I've
gotten a little better like the phone
thing was like this is the last one so
I'm in a new relationship now and then I
was with the painter who I loved for
like four and a half years but we just I
just had time to time communicate my
biggest issue my whole life has been
anger so and like I've been aware of
that and I know that it's the terrible
thing or or thank God because it's why
you're a great comic yeah but but like
it's like I didn't know how to
communicate emotionally and I'd somehow
you know sometimes I get you know angry
but like with the last woman after I
mean I went out with moon for Wilde moon
Zappa for six months and and I broke up
that was very clean it was again it was
just it was right after the the other
woman who I brought you know and I got
in with moon and I used to be in love
with her we had crush on each other we
known each other long time but six
months in I'm like I was just sort of
like I'm not working I can't do it and
it was that clean and then the one I
went out with before Lynn was a painter
and I loved her but there was no drama
it was really easy low-key you know was
a different vibe but there was an age
difference in a world difference and I
just couldn't commit she was how old 40
but I couldn't make her laugh I was
having a hard time communicating with
say in that where's onion while I
started the weird realization the
realization was like I'm 56
I've been married twice I got no kids
and I and I don't have to do anything I
don't want to do and I certainly don't
owe my life to anybody so you know not
for nothing and no no harm no foul in a
way I can't do this anymore and and I
don't want to work on she surprised she
was and I think she was hurt and I and
it was and I felt bad and I still feel
bad but why do i why can't I try to be
happy yeah that's yeah if you know that
like there's a fundamental issue here
that I don't think we're gonna overcome
I gotta go yeah you don't need to be a
martyr and now the nuke and now the new
girl it's a fish she's like a she's like
my age roughly a couple years younger
and we have
a lot in common we understand each other
and there's just such a weight off
it's horrible to be in a relationship
where you like yeah you know and you
love them but you're still like you know
it's not food and I feel bad I guess
we're letting it go on so on but this
one is it's great but because we're so
like then I there's also those kind of
issues like oh yeah you know sort of
like are you just copying me now okay
but I have this new bit where I'm like
um I deal with the anger like I say like
I don't know how to communicate properly
emotionally you know like for instance
like a couple weeks ago I just tried to
start a fight with my girlfriend all day
for nothing though no reason just poking
poking just so eventually she would snap
and I go what's the matter you know like
so so I wish there was an app like why
don't they have an app because like when
you're an [ __ ] you got a few seconds
you know it's gonna have you like it you
feel it coming up and you know but
rarely can you stop it right so why
don't they have an app that you at least
can turn the app on it'll translate what
you really mean when you're an [ __ ]
like like for instance when you go like
[ __ ] you you don't [ __ ] love me then
the app goes I love you very much and
then the other one is like my favorite
is like you you're [ __ ] with my head
you're manipulating me and the apps like
I feel very close to you right now it's
making me uncomfortable
well you know this is this is what makes
you special and your honesty and your I
can't wait to see the special it's
called what end of days end times fun n
times fun
Marc Maron you're my favorites thank you
thank you are you happy with what
happened here I did it for you my
favorites is a store just awesome thanks
for having me I love you Marc Marc Marc
it's funny because I know you you think
we're too bro podcast stuff [ __ ] out
here we love you I need the bros usually
what happens where are you gonna be
we're gonna be spies
what do you when you performing next I
I'm actually just like I'm home for a
while because I'm doing blow I start
glow next week the specials out if I'm
in town and I can I'm always at the
store on weekends you'll sell me at the
store what's your special though Netflix
it's gonna be good Marc Maron
thanks buddy thank you you're awesome